hi Josh so the last time I interviewed
you it was before you were drafted
before you were an NBA player and I
asked you a question which was if you
could build your dream starting five
what would it be okay and you said you
Paul George
Kevin Durant Yanis and Anthony Davis but
I'm curious now that you have played in
the league has that starting five
changed at all we did definitely be I'll
probably say uh our ad Bron Bron in
there I still keep Kady still keep me
honest and still keep baby and me at the
point okay so why it has bran shown you
that made you put him in there now that
you didn't want haven't been there in
the beginning oh just like his feel for
the game like how he can affect the game
in so many ways toughest player that you
had to guard this year psychology
here's Kyrie what made it so difficult
his hand oh so we never know where he
could what he's gonna do
he can shoot the ball he can finish on
the room he who's different type of
moves so you know creates placement
getting shot off just have to be aware
of them at all time he's a great scorer
now the Rookie of the Year race
obviously is something that everybody is
discussing it's obviously come down to
you and Zion Williamson I know you and
Zion or close friends so you can get
that part out of the way but in your
eyes is it even a close race now I feel
like I've I've done enough I deserve for
like my play this year pooled all that
had a great season so far
Toronto you know stop that sort of oh I
know you made a tweet I would hope and
jest when you were saying when Aaron
Gordon lost you're like I'm not doing
this I'm not doing the dunk contest is
that true are you gonna ever do
contest or have you ruled it out as of
now you know I'm not I'm not leaving or
get it up all because of Aaron Gordon
being robbed yeah man it was just so
contest I'm not saying he should have
won and I'm not saying he should have
lost might you just wanted to see it you
know keep going see what other does it
will pull out no just like all of us you
watched the last dance I came in here I
saw you tweeting about it so of course
the number one question is is Michael
Jordan the greatest vaso player of all
time yes
you say yes definitively yes he is what
makes you so sure um you know me at
first I haven't seen Jordan plays like
in person other than like highlights you
know you hear people talk about the last
dance actually you know gave me
opportunity to see how he actually was
like how he played his mindset you know
just watching that taking everything out
of that I think he used to go so before
the documentary who did you think was
the goat I mean my focus was LeBron I
watched Bryant like he was my generation
that's who I grew up watching also I
couldn't speak on somebody I haven't
seen at that point I was just saying
like this generation is him of ours bran
I know my was a big Kobe fan so that
tossed up between him and bronze you
know comments up all around his door you
responded to was his tweet about
surveying NBA players on whether or not
to resume the season and you said I want
to play I wouldn't know if you have
spoken to players who have you know the
opposite feeling that maybe feel like
you guys shouldn't play and how how
prevalent is that sentiment not wanting
to come back I talk to anybody like who
hasn't want to play I'm sure everybody
wants to except for the teams who
probably met in the playoffs
tell me three players that you could not
be quarantined with I'll probably go
with chair okay John Jackson not on the
quarantine list okay okay he tried to
make me wrap his stuff and I'm not a
rapper that's my god
Trey young and I feel like you're trying
to do some chick talks or something I
see my take togs he's doing
impersonations and stuff like that I
couldn't do that and I Kevin Porter
Julia is he like dancing I like dancing
you might be our final question for you
after experiencing the NBA are you still
the point guard yes
that's my mindset you know you don't
believe in yourself [ __ ] we'll all
right thank you so much for your time
Joe I'm so happy for you and I
appreciate you coming on thank you